If we want to define the set Fruit like we did before,
we can write the following, and when I print Fruit I get the following.
Notice that I could have included apple twice,
and when I print I get the exact same thing because sets don't take duplicates into account.
I can also print the set Vegetable and notice that the order that I defined this set in
is not necessarily the order that it gets printed in. Sets don't care about order.
Once we've defined these sets, we can check for membership.
For example, maybe I want to know if apple is in the set Fruit,
and when I run this statement I get a true.
Apple is in Fruit.
Sense apple is not in Vegetable, this statement gives me False.
For a quiz, what's going to be the output when I print this statement:
fruit--with a vertical bar--vegetable? Select the best option.